father's day is approaching quickly and
we are also in graduation season so gift
giving may be at the top of your list
here to help is lifestyle expert
samantha vickers i am so excited we
finally get to do a segment together
and you bring all the good stuff well i
thank you thank you i try and this is a
really good one like it's celebration
all around dad's grads all the good
things right yeah we're looking for a
little something for everyone and yes
you know cheese sign me up let's start
here
so i bought i brought bored and gray's
with me today and this is a cheeseboard
boutique here in the valley and they
make beautiful delicious cheese boards
um for every occasion so you can see on
this one cute little dad sign on here i
don't even notice that that's so cute
on here we've got the 22 for the class
of 22 you know 2022. so really any
occasion really really awesome you can
customize it as little or as big as you
need feed everybody she's got
all sorts of things on the website that
are extras like this hot honey
with spice a little spice yeah and so
you can go to boarding greys.com and
order
look at all the other good things that
she has pick up a gift card for someone
anything you need it's almost too pretty
to eat but i know i know it's delicious
because i've had it before all right
let's move on over here okay so this is
wellness apothecary shop and i love this
stuff because there are no toxins
there's no additives there's nothing
it's all like good stuff like you could
eat the soap oh my gosh not die so it's
it's always good right great
multi-functional yes i mean don't eat
yourself but um this is fun because they
have a whole man collection so they have
the man soap you gotta smell this and it
smells i can smell a lot of hair it
smells super
yeah my dad would love that yeah okay
it's really fun so you can use it for
face hair body any of that and then man
face over here this you can use for
beards you can use aftershave any of
those kind of things and so
really really awesome clean great
company i've used it myself for two and
a half years i love this stuff yeah you
can't go wrong with it yeah and i love
anything that has to do with the salt
room i'm a huge fan of it so tell us
about some gift ideas here yes okay so
the salt room really for dads for grads
anyone who wants to relax who wants to
take a break they have the halo therapy
they've got float therapy that's right
they have massages they have meditation
they have so many things they have these
beautiful salt lamps i mean really
everything everyone on your list can get
something here so
saltroomlv.com and they have three
locations in the valley now yeah they
keep popping up it's a great place to
really relax and unwind and let's move
on down here this is a fun gift basket
you have okay so i had to bring a diy
because those are always fun and this
one would be for you know that cute
little grab in your life that maybe she
loves some candles and some hair things
little snacks a great little mug so
really it's all about putting together
their favorite things to make them feel
really loved and appreciated and you
know all the hard work of getting
through school they need they need a
good little care basket they do and
sometimes gift baskets are the most fun
because you can just throw a lot of
stuff in there it's like a gift that
keeps on giving yes exactly thank you so
much for being here i'm so glad we
finally got to meet and do this together
and we'll see you again soon absolutely
all right now let's send it to ted with
a look at your most accurate weather now
forecast